muitos professores dizem que nós alunos
não temos vontade de estudar mas será
que nós vamos realmente não temos
vontade está até sei que tem uns caras
que não tem mais coisas muitos alunos
que têm vontade está justamente os temas
escola propõe mas tem mais de seu
próprio interesse como por exemplo
futebol esportes artes música
eu por exemplo me interessa por biologia
que vocês disse tardif esse modelo os
tipos de sistemas de transporte por
ônibus
mas como o que vemos hoje pra mim ver
quando ainda era criança quando eu
pegava o meu sono de papelão e colocaram
as personagens fantasiosos para brincar
dentro
esse interesse ele surgiu quando eu
morava lá no acre
andava naqueles anos bem diferentes bem
velhos e capangas estão temendo ser
tratada lá e é esse são muito velhos
assim o time e fazer um barulho muito
alto e aí isso me forma de pensar é
marcante na minha vida isso me marcou me
marcou muito e isso o homem desenvolveu
interesse pela biologia mas como o tempo
não queria que fosse mais uma
brincadeira eu queria que fosse um
estudo sério também então comecei a
estudar e se esse interesse
semente e isso me ajudou a desenvolver
novos conhecimentos na área
eu comecei a estudar também mobilidade
urbana o urbanismo e com isso pôde fazer
vários projetos de brt que é o canaleta
exclusiva para ônibus e fiz os projetos
inclusive para rio branco no acre
eu fiz os projetos em 3d e inclusive
filho também planeja cada detalhe cada
característica do sistema
fiz um corte transversal da avenida
principal onde passaria o sistema e
coloquei as onde ficarão estações nos
corredores as partes onde serão os
carros enfim plano de cada detalhe do
sistema
mas antes de definir se o sistema brt
eu pensei em todos os modais viárias
urbanos possíveis
em usados exerceria metroso seria o
ônibus seria trem e eu também definir
cada local que ficariam as estações para
fazer isso eu estudei muito ver mapas em
tempo real e ajudei toda todos os locais
onde passariam o veículo então planejou
cada detalhe
eu também escrever um livro sobre
sistemas brt do brasil e eu também
coloquei em cada parte dele os detalhes
as histórias dos sistemas mas eu não
quis mais só fazer brts bus logia sem 3d
então comecei a fazer coisas novas
conhecer fazer casas cidades cidades
isso mesmo eu fiz uma cidade inteira
minha planejada em 3d usando o jogo
minecraft como ferramenta não só fiz os
detalhes da mobilidade urbana mas eu
planejei cada parte dos prédios eu
planejei todas as partes dos prédios os
desaires deles a arquitetura como seriam
tudo em 3d
então eu não sei só o minecraft para
fazer prédio mas em outras ferramentas
em 3d
eu fiz é um projeto de prédio
habitacional de muita ver o com uma
personalidade de um personagem
fantasioso da minha infância
esse personagem se chamava o são
ele é uma grande característica que ele
gostava muito de gambiarra
eu brincava que ele gostava de banguela
gambiarra e fazer tudo tudo brincado
assim fazer uma gambiarra gostava de
coisa colorida bem diferente do jeito
dele então eu planejei é parte do prédio
toda pensando nele é muito tinha muito a
ver com a personalidade dele mas eu não
me interessa só por isso ele testa em
por programação de computadores é um
tema que eu já venho trabalhando e
usando desde criança
também mas como que surgiu a programação
pra mim surgiu do meu interesse assim eu
comecei a usar o computador quando tinha
mais ou menos uns sete oito anos de
idade mais ou menos semana da criança eu
usava o computador e comecei a trabalhar
melhor entender melhor como é a
logística do computador trabalhar com
arquivos programas e aí eu comecei a
querer customizar o computador e fazer
ele do meu jeito
eu mudava os ícones das pastas fazer
tudo que eu podia mas não estava aqui
era muito limitado é não podia fazer
tudo o que eu quisesse então eu pensei
assim hoje eu queria mudar o código e
descobri que tinha um código que você
usava para fazer o sistema operacional
no caso e eu queria descobrir como mudá
lo mas é notei que é impossível não
tinha como mudar o código já estava
feito e já estava compilado
então pensei assim se eu não posso mudar
o que já existe que não era open source
eu vou criar o meu próprio sistema
operacional
e foi assim que eu comecei a me
interessa programação
comecei a estudar a programação e
descobrir como fazê-la programação então
eu criei meu próprio sistema operacional
o itaqui e uma grande característica
dele é que ele é todo desenhado à mão
por mim tipo pente assim só que ele
funciona também ele salvar arquivos é
igual a ele guarda os arquivos tem um
método de gerenciamento programas e tem
umas idéias novas também para sistemas
operacionais é eu fiz um estudo próprio
uma análise minha pessoal e notei e
todas as minhas meus interesses próprios
na minha vida surgiram por uma
experiência marcante
então eu continuei a análise e notei que
quase nenhuma das minhas experiências
marcantes tinha sucedido na escola
na minha escola não tinha surgido nenhum
dos meus interesses próprios
então como teve experiências marcantes
na escola sá que assistindo a nossa de
cada dia
seg às aulas nossa de cada dia nos
proporcionam experiências marcantes na
minha opinião não porque são todas
iguais sempre sobre temas que o
professor traz se torna muito massivas
muito chatas não são experiências
marcantes dos alunos
então como ter experiências marcantes na
escola
a minha proposta é que seja feita a
troca de conhecimento ou também
compartilhamento de conhecimento na qual
não só o professor traz os temas de de
estudo para a sala de aula mas a qual os
alunos também podem trazer temas de
interesse seu próprios para a sala de
aula e assim formar uma roda de
discussão de conversa na qual os alunos
de professores discutem os temas que
estão sendo trabalhados no momento e
assim todos acabam se beneficiando e
aprendendo os conteúdos neste caso é
interessante que o professor seja mais
um instigador do conhecimento do que o
próprio cara que traz de tudo meu
colégio anualmente é acontece uma foi um
evento chamado feira do conhecimento na
qual o tipo uma expo assim onde os
alunos expõem seus projetos e trabalhos
realizados durante o ano por esses
trabalhos são todos dirigidos pela
escola planejados pela escola e os
alunos são mandados fazer é pela escola
para fazer esse aluno esse trabalho
então na hora parece uma experiência
marcante parece ser uma troca de
conhecimento
mas não é porque o conhecimento na vida
dos alunos está vindo da escola
os projetos são a escola que definiu
como os alunos têm que fazer num assunto
projetos pessoais dos alunos
eles apenas estão fazendo que a escola
pediu então uma verdadeira feira do
conhecimento onde houvesse troca de
conhecimento
ouve-se troca vai ser às vezes marcantes
seria uma feira onde os alunos pudessem
exibir seus projetos pessoais
essas pesquisas pessoais
se fosse uma
oportunidades onde eles pudessem mostrar
seus projetos pessoais em um local
público e disney realizada a troca de
conhecimento outras pessoas também
poderiam expor seus projetos e assim
algumas pessoas vão aprender com as
outras inclusive os professores enquanto
que os professores vão valorizar tudo
isso muitos acham que não é importante
que não é conhecimento que não vai
ajudar nas escolas os alunos a ficarem
mais interessados
quando eles vão valorizar mas é claro
que já conhecimento porque o cara tá ali
ele está aprendendo
mesmo que não seja um conhecimento
reconhecido pelos professores está
aprendendo vai levar aquilo para o resto
da vida dele vai carregar aquilo como
conhecimento e todas aqui estou falando
que eu sou um gênio vizinho uma luz
especial nerd
estou falando aqui porque eu sou um
aluno normal como qualquer todos os
outros e até de tudo um colégio
tradicional como todos os outros alunos
da minha idade
então eu digo os alunos para que eles
não deixem seus projetos pessoais se
perderem a que eles corram atrás dos
seus projetos pessoais
isso também vale para os adultos e os
seus projectos pessoais do passado para
que eles não deixem cair e não deixem
eles morro que outras coisas a basf eu
digo lembre se de suas experiências
marcantes
obrigado